les communautés autochtones dénoncent
depuis des années les coupes forestières
sur leur territoire mais comment
protéger la forêt quand l'industrie n'y
voit que des mètres cubes de bois une
solution qu'ont trouvé certaines
premières nations en abitibi
témiscamingue
c'est de valoriser les produits agro
forestiers comme les champignons
[Musique]
nous sommes dans une forêt qui était sur
le point d'être coupé et ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'un des paliers du
gouvernement nous envoyer une
consultation et nous a dit nous
aimerions couper cette sombre avez vous
des commentaires
et on a répondu oui c'est ici qu'on
cueille nos chanterelle
[Musique]
réactions ont été très positifs
finalement cette forêt sera sans doute
préservé donc c'est une victoire et les
victoires sont très rares
[Musique]
on récolte avant tout les champignons
qui sont comestibles mais aussi
commercialisable
comme ça on s'assure que leur valeur est
élevé
on cueille des chanterelles qui sont
très populaires des champignons aux
morts des pleurotes en huîtres qui sont
également populaires je pourrais en
nommer plusieurs autres
tara dans tout ce travail au département
des ressources naturelles de
témiscamingue first nation elle a
cofondé le projet white basket pour
valoriser les produits forestiers
comestibles avec l'aide géomaticien
denis bisson qui travaille avec eux
depuis près de 20 ans
mon prochain pour les aider à créer le
département des ressources naturelles
qui s'occupait à peu près toutes les
ressources du territoire on essaie
penser à des nouveaux projets qu'on
pourrait développer qui preuve qui
permettrait de créer de l'emploi qui
permettrait aux gens de retourner sous
territoires de plus en plus puis on
avait entendu parler des projets comme
ceux des projets de produits forestiers
non ligneux ils ont fait le pari de
mettre les champignons au goût du jour
même s'ils ne font pas partie de la
culture anissina be on a été présenté le
projet aux groupes des années de la
communauté et on fait une petite
dégustation de chanterelles que les
années sont tous devant new line au
regard d'un drôle d'air au laser pense
vraiment que je vais manger sa finale un
premier de la partie le plus drôle c'est
qu'elle est née je pense appuyé du
groupe dit de toute façon je suis le
plus vieil fait que je prends ma chance
puis l ai pris une bouchée pilosité il
fallut retourne en forêt à rechercher de
cet après midi là pour réussir à suffire
à la demande puis depuis ce temps là
beaucoup d'aînés de la communauté sont
les meilleurs acheteurs des produits de
waele basque ils vendent le fruit des
cueillettes aux gens de la communauté et
de la région en plus de fournir
plusieurs restaurateurs
et la vision de basket a toujours été
centrée sur l'utilisation du territoire
c'est vraiment important pour nous de
donner aux membres de la communauté à un
outil pour se reconnecter à la forêt ça
a toujours été notre objectif numéro un
l'autre objectif était de fournir des
emplois aux membres de la communauté et
nous avons réussi
nous avons embauché cinq six personnes à
peu près au cours des six dernières
années
soc 10
soldats des fanci santander producer
linder
pour trouver les champignons l'équipe de
wilde basket utilise les cartes créées
par dany buisson ce sont des cartes de
potentiel de plantes et de petits fruits
est désormais de champignons sauces et
des habitats potentiel de thise labrador
ce qu'on voit ici c'est la fréquence
si vous allez dans les polygones en
rouge vous avez entre 70 et 100 % de
chances de retrouver du thé du labrador
au niveau des champignons on a moins
d'informations donc ce qu'on fait
finalement haut niveau avec différents
habitats chaque couleur représentent des
groupes de champignons qui ont à peu
près le même habitat travers on peut
avoir par exemple matsutake chanterelle
commune champignons dermatoses des
russules l'eau sert vraiment de toutes
sortes de choses auxerre dimanche et
élite on sert de photos aériennes on
sert de base de données qu'on est rendu
à 40 ou 50 mille parcelles d'inventaire
qu'on a compilé depuis 20 30 ans
s'écarte de potentiels sont conçues pour
protéger le territoire et mieux gérer la
ressource elles ne sont pas accessibles
à tout le monde
à 300 kilomètres de là le succès de why
basket a inspiré une autre communauté
autochtone qui souhaite aussi changer la
vocation des forêts dany buisson
rencontre ronald brazeau directeur par
intérim du département de ressources
naturelles de la communauté du lac simon
jamais l'écart pour des projets
c'est la carte train de préparer avec un
opinel pour les épisodes différents
espèces de champignons peu comme si oui
il ya du potentiel un peu partout c'est
le seimat cette équipe jeu vidéo c'est
dermato d'amateurs soins puisque c'est
tout lire et très mécontent ciel nous on
est quand même un peu en colère
participants on sait pas comment ces
lieux où est la beetle puis avec vincent
puis renoncé d'aller chercher un bus un
plus d' expertise
la connaissance du territoire couplée
aux cartes a permis de retarder une
coupe forestière de cinq ans mais dont
la demande doit être renouvelé chaque
année on s'est vite rendu compte c'est
le dernier secteur le dernier massif de
pins gris il fallait agir vite pour
pouvoir mettre en place un projet
novateur de micro 6,8 une seule
excellent et
[Musique]
il aménage la forêt pour produire des
champignons de grande valeur le
matsutake prisée par les japonais et le
champignon omar aussi appelé dermatoses
des russules on serait intéressé par
sciemment aux champignons des pins gris
dans le projet parce que le berry c'est
une des forêts qui est la plus menacée
au québec est très convoité par
l'industrie forestière
elles recèlent les champignons les plus
ne plus avoir de l'importance de ce
projet là de développer les techniques
de production du match taquet pour
permettre aussi de sauvegarder certains
îlots pour la recherche mais aussi pour
le développement si un jour vraiment se
rend compte que c'est super intéressant
la production de champion puis ça
devient un produit agro forestiers comme
le bleu et le sirop d'érable
ce qu'on veut c'est les sports ici
qu'ils vont aller dans l'eau
près sûr de faire une bonne solution
le secteur où on implante la dermatose
des reçus donc ce qu'on fait comme
travaux ont fait des perturbations qu'on
va gratter le sol avec une herse dans
l'objectif de par la suite apporter une
solution de sport et de mycélium de
dermatose des russules et de recul pour
créer une implantation
mais on a d'autres et c'est aussi qu'on
veut aussi faire des petites éclaircies
pour permettre au sol de se réchauffer
pour permettre aux mycélium de croître
de façon beaucoup plus optimale
ça vous des opportunités d'embauché on a
des bûcherons aussi sur le terrain qui
vient de la communauté qui ont pas
nécessairement
facilement les contrôles des travaux
d'après radar ça c'est d'intégrer les
jeunes aussi de la communauté parce que
si on s'en cachera pas là dessus les
jeunes peuvent poster s'identifier
à long terme l'équipe espère créer une
réserve mycologique et développer le mic
au tourisme afin de faire connaître la
valeur de la filière comme on peut le
voir en espagne
on parle quand même de revenus
intéressants le
c'est par ce genre d'aménagement là
c'est juste je pense l'un d'eux un peu
plus de 20 kilos à l'hectare 50 dollars
le kilo ou ses 1000 $ par année par
hector donc sur 40 ans et 40 millions
d'euros versus ses 5000 pour la co mais
on a quand même la cour
elle seule la valeur économique des
champignons forestiers ne suffira pas à
stopper l'exploitation forestière
l'industrie est un gros lobby très
puissant price à la source et sa
mainmise dessus donc d'arriver à
à implanter ce genre de projet c'est ça
la présente certains défis l'eau
le ministère des forêts de la faune et
des parcs du québec qui réglemente les
travaux forestiers aux forêts publiques
a décliné notre demande d'entrevue
concernant la pérennité d'un tel projet
ils disent ne pas être responsable de
développer le domaine des produits
forestiers non ligneux
je pense que la prochaine étape pour
nous les premières nations c'est de
créer nos propres entreprises
forestières c'est à nous de déterminer
ce qui sera coupé ou non
est ce qu'on va utiliser des herbicides
pour que les arbres poussent
parfaitement non il ya beaucoup d'argent
en jeu et l'industrie ne veut pas
partager sa part de gâteau
donc oui c'est un immense défi de faire
affaire avec les compagnies forestières
[Musique]